I always wonder who's watching our
videos and Brady has now got lots of
photos so I can begin to see who some of
our viewers are and it's great fun we've
shown you some already and we've got
lots more so let's have a look at some
fun
there quite a few from different school
classes there's one I particularly like
from a class in Serbia in the school in
Novi Sad where you can see they're
watching my video on Bunsen burner
then another school has made a periodic
table cake several of our viewers have
periodic table t-shirts one has some
strange chemical shirt that I don't
quite understand but it's her favorite
two young fans have made a periodic
table out of Lego that's really work of
love one fan has papered a periodic
table on the wall of his bedroom but it
wasn't big enough on one wall so he's
got a sort of three dimensional periodic
table that looks real fun one bang has
really gone to town with the periodic
table on the wall on the t-shirt and
with a mug like mine so full marks for
that
people watch with all sorts of size
screen from handheld iPhones or similar
up to huge screens I never imagined that
anybody could watch her videos on such
big picture
people seem to watch with our pets we've
got several cats the dog and they also
watch with their family there's one
family that seems to eat of periodic
table table mats one for each member of
the family and I particularly like the
picture of one viewer who watches with
his grandmother there's one viewer with
a molecule of c60 buckyball on the head
and then and a really nice one with a
molecule tattooed on his arm but we're
saving that one for a video
there's one photo that really entreats
me and I'll leave you to guess why we're
always looking out for more photos so
keep the photos coming because we really
want to get to know our audience brady
who is very keen on prizes is going to
organize some random prizes for those
who send in their photos so keep them
coming and you may get a prize